this dilapidated apartment building is
one of hundreds in johannesburg's inner
city
it's where known to zomato and her
family live she was born in South
Africa's Eastern Cape Province and moved
to Johannesburg with her husband in
1998. she sees four adults and six
children share one room the toilets are
not clean
and you are staying with kids here
you know we
let you gonna get
affected with the diseases because of
the place
they don't pay rent one reason why they
are still here I can't move because I
don't have money I'm not working anymore
several blocks abandoned by their owners
or city authorities are full of families
City officials call them hijacked
buildings
this building has 14 floors and 420
rooms each apartment is occupied there's
no running water and there's no
electricity it's been like that for
years
some people pay rent to criminal gangs
who run the buildings South Africa has a
housing crisis a legacy of apartheid and
a huge challenge for the governing
African National Congress I think it's
over 300 000 in terms of our bad luck on
housing our people and you'd understand
that at no point you'll arrive and say
Johannesburg is a reserved despite local
housing
precisely because every month we receive
at least 18 000 people flogging into
Johannesburg the 15 of those 15 000 of
those who probably from our provinces
all the eight other provinces and about
three thousand of those will be from
foreign countries flogging Johannesburg
with the hope of finding opportunities
last month more than 70 people died when
this apartment in Johannesburg caught
fire
as survivors and relatives mourn the
Dead the disaster reminded South
Africans of the levels of poverty and
Desperation here and that is one of the
most unequal Societies in the world
haramutasa Al Jazeera Johannesburg
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera